- Well, I think
when the rumor broke
that we were going to
do something bigger,
well, and I started
hearing rumblings,
and then these 39
professors attacked.
This is prior to the event,
and then we started hearing
rumors that the students
were intimidated and threatened.
If you show up at that event,
you might not get
that grade you want.
And so it was intimidation,
it was muscle,
it was everything
we don't stand for.
And these, I mean, I'm
not fond of education,
as you may know from my history.
I learned nothing
about money at school.
I had to learn it
from my rich dad
who was a high school dropout.
But anyway, it was horrifying.
I said to Ann, I said, "I
told you this would happen."
But David, it got worse.
(gentle music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining
me today is investor,
entrepreneur, and author
of "Rich Dad Poor Dad,"
former Rubin Report
guest, Robert Kiyosaki,
and free speech advocate
and former executive,
I put emphasis on former,
former executive director
of the Lewis Center at
Arizona State University,
Ann Atkinson, Robert, Ann,
welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
- Robert, I'm gonna start with
you because I put emphasis
on former in Ann's intro,
but sort of you coming
to ASU is what caused
the former part in her intro,
so why don't you set us
up as to why you guys
are here together,
and then, Ann,
we'll get to your involvement
in this whole thing.
- Well, let me go
way back in time.
In 1965, I read this book here,
"The Communist Manifesto."
I went to military school.
(ring knocking)
I'm a ring knocker.
And then I went to
Vietnam as a Marine pilot.
I flew these babies in Vietnam.
Shot a lot of
communists out there.
And then I came
walking home, you know,
Johnny comes marching home
again, hurrah, hurrah.
I got spit on and hit with eggs
at Norton Air Force Base,
just north of San Francisco.
Interesting, isn't it?
And I'm afraid what's
happened to America
is we have gone Marxist.
And so when Ann invited me
to Arizona State University,
which is the largest
university in America,
I said, "No way, I'm not going."
Just because I had
such a bad experience
at the University of Hawaii,
I got spit on there too.
I was in the MBA program
and I dropped out.
So when Ann asked me, "Would
you mind teaching at ASU,"
I said, "I'd rather go back
to Vietnam and shoot people."
It's more honest.
You know what I mean?
I'm a sick Marine, you
guys understand that.
And so she says, "I promise you,
I promise you I'll
protect you," and she did.
She thought was
just a Lewis Center
is the Barrett's Honors College,
Dave, these were the brightest
of the brightest, you know,
people I never hung out
with at school. (laughs)
And it was a fabulous, it
was all in entrepreneurship.
I brought my oil guy in,
my cattle guy, my 401K,
I don't do 401K, but
brought my stock guy in
and all this stuff.
It was fabulous and then Ann
says, "Let's do it again."
I'm going, "Okay, she
sucked me in." (laughs)
So that was last
summer, and so December,
I mean February, we
did an event called
"Health, Wealth and Happiness"
on Arizona State
Campus University.
Health, Wealth, Happiness
featuring Dennis Prager,
and unfortunately,
Charlie Kirk, who,
as a Marine pilot would say,
"We drew a lot of fire."
And these woke professors,
39 of 'em came after us.
And Dave, it's still,
we're still fighting.
That was last February.
We were at the Arizona
State Legislature.
They're taking action
against these 39 professors
for intimidation, threats.
I can't believe how Marxists
and woke they've gotten
and Ann got fired because of it.
- Right.
- I can't believe it.
- So, Robert, you called me
a couple weeks ago, said,
"Have you heard
about this story?"
I started doing some Googling.
It really was sort of
blowing up in Arizona,
but hasn't kind of
made it national.
That's why I wanted to talk
to you guys about this,
because first off, this one,
everyone knows me
and free speech,
but then this one felt personal
because, Robert, we're friends.
And then you're on stage
with two of my other buddies,
Dennis, who's become
like an uncle to me,
and Charlie, who's a
good buddy of mine,
these are not haters, these
are not mean, evil people
and you're talking about success
and wealth and happiness,
all of these things.
These are not far right,
crazy, mean, racist things.
So Ann, can you explain a bit
about why you invited them
and then what the pushback
was that kind of led
to the whole bruhha now
how it's gotten involved
with the state legislature even?
- Yes, Dave, I will.
So for the last two years I've
been the executive director
of the TW Lewis Center
for Personal Development,
which is a center of Barrett,
the Honors College
at Arizona State.
Barrett has 7,000 students
and the purpose of the
Lewis Center was to teach
those students about
entrepreneurship,
career success,
happiness, personal
finance and meaning,
but also to teach the
traditional American values
of personal responsibility,
hard work, civic duty,
faith, family and
community service.
So in my role as
executive director,
we put on and I oversaw
programming for the students.
And in the last two years
we had nearly 150 programs.
This was one of them.
The topics of health,
wealth, and happiness
were directly aligned with the
intent of the Lewis Center,
which was established by
ASU and its honors college.
So with this event,
we decided to have
a normal Lewis Center
speaker program,
but to make it
available to the public.
The Lewis Center's not
a political center.
This was not even a
political program,
but health, wealth and
happiness led to censorship,
condemnation, and chillings,
and ultimately my firing
and the firing of the person
for the event venue who
put this on, on our behalf.
- Okay, so Robert, you
guys show up to the event.
It's a public event
at the school.
When did you realize that there
were gonna be some problems?
Were they shouting you down
at the beginning of the event?
Were there protests beforehand?
When did it sort of
escalate into something
other than just the usual stuff
that happens on
college campuses?
- Well, I think
when the rumor broke
that we were going to do
something bigger, well,
and I started hearing rumblings
and then these 39
professors attacked.
This is prior to the event.
And then we started hearing
rumors that the students
were intimidated and threatened.
If you show up at that event,
you might not get
that grade you want.
And so it was intimidation,
it was muscle,
it was everything
we don't stand for.
And these, I mean, I'm
not fond of education,
as you may know from my history.
I'd learned nothing
about money at school.
I had to learn it
from my rich dad
who was a high school
dropout, but anyway,
it was horrifying.
And I said to Ann, I said, "I
told you this would happen."
But David, it got worse.
And these guys, there's a saying
that the Japanese, Chinese,
and any educated person says,
"If you find yourself in
a hole, stop digging."
Well, dumb ass these 39
professors keep digging
and they're still digging.
And the Arizona Senate is
now doing an investigation
into 'em and the head
of the Senate said,
"There will be
people being fired."
There's nothing more
terrifying to a professor,
like my poor dad,
than being fired.
- Okay, so Ann,
these 39 professors,
did they show up to the event?
I mean they were
telling their kids,
in essence, before the event,
"Do not show up or it's
gonna hurt your grade."
And do you have records
of this kind of stuff?
- I have records of everything.
The 39 out of the
47 honors faculty
ran this national
condemnation campaign,
which started with
their petition that
called Dennis Prager
and Charlie Kirk white
nationalist provocateurs,
bigoted, extreme
anti-intellectual,
anti-democratic, purveyors of
hate who've publicly attacked
women, people of color, the
LGBTQ community and so forth.
And then Robert was
accused of being dangerous
because he teaches about debt.
So it didn't, this was
not innocent clatter.
- (laughs) About
debt, about debt.
You are dangerous
to debt, Robert.
- I say debt and taxes
make the rich richer.
You know, I don't pay
tax like Donald Trump.
You know what I mean?
We're real estate guys.
The teachers went nuts.
- So this didn't end,
though, with the petition
to their deans.
The professors went into their
classroom where they teach
mandatory honors classes to
freshmen to condemn our program,
our speakers, our donors,
and the leadership and
staff of the Lewis Center.
The professors used ASU
resources, computers, equipment,
in their official
capacity to do so,
which leads to state action.
That is a state
actionable offense.
The professors went campus-wide
outside of the honors college
for help to drive a mission
to condemn all of those parties.
And then they went
further on a national
condemnation campaign,
painting this and labeling this
as hate speech.
- Okay, so Robert, I hate to
tell ya that when you called me
about this, I think I
said to you on the phone,
"I'm not surprised," right?
Like there's nothing
that would surprise me
about any sane person
showing up to a university
and being told that they
were evil and all that stuff.
- Right, right.
- I think what surprises
people to some extent still
is that is how much of
this comes from faculty
'cause I think most
people are used to seeing
the kids go crazy now.
Like everyone's kind of
used to blue-haired students
screaming somebody down.
But Ann, what you're connecting
to this too is the faculty.
So, I guess from here,
how did you end up
as former director?
And then we'll go from there.
- Yes, and I'll add, Dave,
it's not just the faculty.
The deans censored speech.
The deans of my college
censored speech.
They told me Robert
Kiyosaki, Dennis Prager,
and Dr. Rajagopalan,
who were on the panel,
were only to talk about
health, wealth, and happiness
and they were not to speak
about higher education
or anything that could
be deemed political
or used as a political platform.
- Wow.
- So, a university
that's celebrated for
its free speech policies,
college deans undermined
that by saying what speech
was allowed and what
speech wasn't allowed.
Further, the deans pulled
down all of the marketing
from the walls around the
Barrett Honors College complex,
citing it was
offending the faculty.
And that's why they
discriminated against our speech
and they allowed opposing
faculty to market
an opposition event
that painted our event
as dangerous hate speech.
- So it was faculty
and administration,
but how does that get to
you being former director
of the center?
- Yes, well, this was
the perfect opportunity
for the new dean at
Barrett, the Honors College,
to eradicate the values that
are evidently no longer allowed
at the college, so after the
faculty attacked our donor,
Tom Lewis, our main donor,
and our other donors
to the Lewis Center,
after the Barrett deans
mishandled the situation, our
main donor, Mr. Tom Lewis,
who's donated millions of
dollars to Arizona State
over the last two decades, left,
the faculty scared him out.
So I brought in new
diversified donor funding
to keep the intent of
the Lewis Center going,
which back to the first
part of our conversation,
included things like
personal responsibility,
hard work, faith, family,
community service.
The new dean took this
opportunity to dismantle a gem
at the Honors college and she
said, "The funding is gone,
therefore we need to fire you."
Yet, and then between
the time when Tom Lewis
notified the college he
would be terminating,
and the time that
actually took effect,
I brought in new
diversified donor funding.
The dean turned it down.
So ASU has stuck firmly
to the position on this
that we lost donor funding,
therefore my position as
executive director goes with it,
but they're not saying the dean
explicitly turns
down new funding.
She didn't ask,
"Who are the donors?
Let's have a conversation.
Meet with the ASU Foundation."
She was purely not
interested so she fired me
effective June 30 when
Tom Lewis's funding ended
and dismantled a gem
at ASU Honors College
and eradicated these values
that are obviously no longer
aligned with the college.
- Yeah, wow, I mean,
this really does sound
like another version
of what happened
to Bret Weinstein
up at Evergreen
and has happened to a whole
bunch of other professors
and faculty at colleges
across the country.
Robert, did anything
happen at the event?
I mean, so you
guys do the event.
I mean, were kids outraged?
Did anyone say anything
that was untoward?
Did you scare anybody
with talk of debt?
- Well, Dave, the problem
was the students loved us.
- Of course.
- (indistinct)
Students protested.
These students
showed up en masse.
They were happy,
they sent all their,
it turned out great
'cause Kari Lake took,
you know, she was
ran for governor.
She had the same ballot box
boogie that Trump has, you know.
- Different topic,
different topic.
- I know, but anyway,
so Kari stepped up
and it was an
overwhelming success
'cause the community stepped up.
And again, I'll reiterate this.
I flew this for the
US Marine Corps.
I'm not the brightest
guy on earth.
They said, "Don't be political,"
so I showed up in my
Marine flight jacket
and I held this book up for
all the teachers and I said,
"You guys should read this
book and find out who you are."
So it went off the
rails from there, Dave.
(panel laughing)
- Ann, can you tell me a little
bit more about the teachers,
I mean, are these
across disciplines?
Did you have a sense
of what all their
political leanings were?
Have any of them now realizing
that this is becoming a story,
have any of them retracted
some of the things they've said
or anything like that?
- Well, certainly, the teacher
who had multiple students
provide testimonies to the
joint legislative session
confirming that she used
her classroom to tell them
not to attend the program,
she's put out a public
statement denying it,
but she doesn't know
there are recordings
of from within her
classrooms that confirmed
the opposite of
what she's denied.
- Well, she might know that now.
(Robert laughing)
- Look, the teachers
study all sorts of topics.
Those that are leading
this condemnation effort,
they study witchcraft, the
practice teaching of witchcraft.
They study gender
theory, settler
colonialism, gun culture.
But look, my view is they
have the right to do that.
If they wanna have an
event on witchcraft
and students want to
attend, I support that.
I think our programs are
slightly better attended.
But I think we all have a
place in higher education
to provide something different.
So the professors have
a range of backgrounds.
They teach freshmen,
They're technically lecturers,
so they're not full
professors at ASU,
but they have just collectively
shamed this speech,
health, wealth and happiness,
and the values of the Lewis
Center is hateful and dangerous.
- And so what exactly
is going on now
with the state legislature
related to all this?
Because obviously the
school gets state funding,
I'm sure there's all
sorts of connections
between the school
and the state.
- That's right, well,
it's really unfortunate
what is needed to happen
is I've been taking
the last several
months to address
these concerns internally.
I've gone through all
the proper ASU channels.
I even went to the
president of the university
and the entire board of regents
with the summary of basically
what I testified about
in our hearing this week.
The answer the university told
me, "We allowed the speakers,
but you then have to
take the consequences."
And when I addressed
the toxicity that's
come around Barrett
since our new dean came
on board a year ago,
they said it was my fault
for inviting the speakers.
They didn't say it's a weak
leader that brought with her
a vacuum to the honors
college that allowed
the faculty to run rampant.
So I exhausted all options
to address things internally
with my alma mater,
and unfortunately, it's
taking legislative action,
so to answer your
question, Dave,
there was an ad hoc
joint session between
the Arizona State Senate
and House of Representatives
this Tuesday, July 18th
and they investigated this
free speech crisis at ASU.
Robert was there
for the whole thing.
I testified, another professor,
Dr. Owen Anderson, testified
in support of free speech,
Seth Leibsohn testified,
and Dennis Prager even
came here from California
to testify in his defense.
So we had this ad hoc hearing,
a 5 1/2 hour long hearing
to present the facts.
ASU is still denying that
there was any wrongdoing.
I think generally, ASU has
great free speech policies
and I keep saying we have
one of the most free
speech presidents,
pro-free speech
presidents in the country,
but all of this is
undermining those policies.
So what happens next?
The senate judiciary committee
in the State of Arizona
is taking this up.
They have ordered a 60-day
deadline for Arizona State
to report on the
information presented
and they'll determine
next steps upon receiving
that report in 60 days.
- Robert, as the sort
of outsider here,
what do you want to happen?
Because I sense a little bit
of kind of shout and Freud
with you on this.
It's like I know
you well enough.
You don't think that a kid
needs the four-year education
and the debt and all of that
stuff to become successful.
- Right.
- So I can sense
in a certain way
you're sort of like,
"Well, of course this happens.
This is the ridiculous way
that the American education
system works or does not work."
- Well the teachers
who teach witchcraft,
they didn't show up
because they couldn't park
their brooms anywhere.
(panel laughing)
Dave, now you know why I
get kicked out of school,
'cause I'm a wise-ass.
- You can't go
after witches, man.
That's the line.
- That's dangerous.
- Yeah.
- Dave, this is the story
of "Rich Dad Poor
Dad" magnified 1,000%.
My poor dad was a
very, very good man,
but at the core, a Marxist.
They're not bad people.
I support the freedom to choose,
but they don't know they are.
They don't know they are.
And they talk about, you know,
America was founded not in 1619,
like the New York Times
wants us to believe.
America was founded in 1773.
It was called the
Boston Tea Party.
And I fight for freedom of taxes
and Marxism as a
progressive income tax
is essential for the
spread of communism.
So when you start, if
you read this book here.
I wrote this book
here in counter to,
it's called the
"Capitalist Manifesto"
because I am a US Marine,
I'm Academy graduate,
and I fight for the
freedom of principle.
I don't fight for people.
I fought for principle that
allow us our freedom of speech.
- Well, and clearly you
could see why a guy like him
would be considered
controversial at Arizona State.
You know, guys, as a total
sidebar, you will love this.
About seven years ago I spoke
at Arizona State University
with Michael Shermer,
who you might know
from Skeptic Magazine.
And at the end of all my talks,
I always say to the audience,
if you disagree with me,
you can come up and
ask questions first.
And as a joke, at the
beginning of the talk, I said,
"How many liberals are here?
How many conservatives here?"
I said, "By raise of hands,
how many Nazis are here?"
And one woman raised her
hand in the back and said
she was a Nazi.
So I said, at the
end during the Q&A,
if you don't shout me down,
you can ask the first question.
It turned out she was
actually a trans Nazi,
yes, believe it or
not, a trans Nazi.
And she didn't believe that
the gas chambers existed
and a whole bunch
of other stuff.
And Michael Shermer, who
debunks these things, did,
and we had an incredible
event on free speech
where we debated things
and I don't know that we
changed the trans Nazi's mind,
but that's my memory
of Arizona State,
so that's why this
is so disappointing.
So, Ann, what do you
want to happen now?
I mean, I suppose you want,
do you want these
professors to be let go?
I mean, do you
want your job back?
- Well, I don't
want my job back.
I've already explored that
with university leadership.
I'm clearly not welcome,
certainly at Barrett,
the honors college.
Look, ASU, the
world is watching.
This has become
a national story.
ASU is an example in free speech
and they need to make it clear
what they will and
won't tolerate.
Right now, ASU is sending a
message to the faculty majority
that it's okay to
bully, suppress,
intimidate and censor speech.
They're sending a
message to people like me
who run centers or programs
in the ideological minority
that you better not speak up
because you will
risk condemnation,
retaliation, and you
probably will lose your job.
So I really, I've been trying
to appeal to the better people
in ASU to take action
to actually investigate,
but yet, in these months,
no one has asked me once
for more information,
for a conversation where
they can to ask questions.
So I'm hoping that
ASU will step in,
but it might take action from
the Arizona State Legislature.
It might take action from
the Arizona Board of Regents,
but this simply is a disgrace
to one of the great
universities in our country.
- Ann, are you getting,
I think you sort of
just answered this,
but I know when Brett
was dealing with
all of the craziness
at Evergreen, he kept
telling me privately
how so many professors were
supporting him privately,
but nobody would step up
and say anything publicly.
I assume you're getting
some version of that.
I think you kind
of alluded to that.
- Exactly, and they're
afraid to speak out
and it's not just
the professors.
Actually more students
have reached out to me
than professors and
the students say,
"Look, I want to go
meet with the dean,
but I'm afraid I'm
gonna risk my grades
or my living arrangements,
or have some
retaliation if I do."
So the professors
created a culture of fear
around this event
because they painted it
as a white supremacy event.
Keep in mind, Robert Kiyosaki-
- Yeah, Robert, you're a
hell of a white supremacist.
- He's American.
Dennis Prager is
a religious Jew.
Dr. Rajagopalan was
raised in Sri Lanka,
and yet I had to defend
comparisons to the KKK
in a meeting with my dean.
The events operations manager
who was fired at the venue
was asked by the executive
director of ASU Gammage,
why did you allow a white
supremacist on our stage?
(Robert laughing)
So they're silencing
the students with
this climate of fear.
So it's the students that are
really the concerning people
that have been reaching
out in droves to express
their support for this, but
their fear of retribution.
- So, Robert, I know
as a capitalist,
you like to create
rather than destroy.
You've got a couple bucks.
What about creating a
new free speech center
at a more free
speech-friendly college?
We've got a couple of 'em
here in Florida, by the way.
- You're reading my mind,
David, you're reading my mind.
You know, there was an old
movie about "Tora! Tora! Tora!"
about my ancestors.
I was on the American side,
they attacked Pearl Harbor.
And then this Japanese
Admiral Yamato,
after he bombed Pearl
Harbor, he says,
"I think we just pissed
off the Americans."
And now these teachers
have pissed me off,
so I'm gonna come after 'em.
- Yeah, I mean, you
just gotta fight back.
Well, Ann, as I said to you
right before we started,
you know, I've been
through this conversation,
some version of it
many times on my show.
Some people don't expect
to be in the fight.
Some people don't
wanna be in the fight
and they end up in it anyway.
I sense you're ready to be in it
and you're gonna see
this thing through, huh?
- I am fully immersed and
fully committed to supporting
an environment that
really allows free speech
for all viewpoints.
So I'll speak with other media,
I will continue this mission
until there's a resolution.
I hope you can see I'm
not criticizing ASU,
I'm simply highlighting gross
undermining of these policies
that suppresses so many
people in the community
so if I have a role to
play in this, I'm game.
- Where can we point people to
if they want more information
on what's going on or
maybe how they can help,
that sort of thing?
- Sure thing. I'm on
Instagram, LinkedIn,
they can email, contact
AnnAtkinson@gmail.com.
I don't yet have
fancy media contacts,
but I suppose maybe
we'll set something up.
- Okay, we'll post
some links down below.
And Robert, what's next on
your freedom fighting frontier?
- Well, like I said, I'm gonna
promote this book even more
like I did at ASU.
People should read this book.
Do you know what I mean?
- You're selling more "Communist
Manifestos" than anybody.
It's really ironic.
- I know.
I'm an author, you know,
but if I could write
a book this powerful,
I'd be proud of myself.
But this, it was
written in 1848, David.
It's more true today
than ever before.
And what this book
says that communism
would take over
America in two stages.
The first stage happened in
1930 when Columbia University,
where Dennis Prager
went to school,
they invited in professors
from the Communist
League of Germany.
And so these communists
came into Columbia
University in 1930,
and from there, rioting
spread to schools
all across the country.
So when I was at school,
I went to the Academy,
Kings Boy March Academy.
There was rioting at
Columbia University,
and then there was Kent
State and all that,
and, you know, Berkeley.
And rioting has spread
across the country.
Unfortunately, those
students are now professors.
So I jokingly say that
when I was standing,
I came to Norton Air Force Base.
I flew in from Vietnam,
I brought my 16
men home all alive.
I'm getting hit on,
spit on, hit with eggs
and all this stuff
and I jokingly say,
'cause as you may guess,
most of my audiences
are fairly conservative.
I certainly say, you know,
I look at those audience of,
you know, students my age,
the hippie generation,
the Woodstock generation
throwing eggs at me, I said,
"I swear to God, that was Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer."
(panel laughing)
But I think they became
our leaders, David.
Does that make sense to you?
- No, it does make sense.
We clearly see what the
universities have done
from way back then
to exactly right now,
which is the whole point of
the book that you're holding
that to be clear, you did not
write, but you're promoting,
you're promoting it for all
the wrong reasons, I get why.
Now promote your own book
so that people understand
the antidote to that lunacy.
- Well, I just wrote this,
this is how big it had to be
just to respond
at how communism,
exactly as this book said,
it could come in two stages.
He predicted it.
Marx was in 1848.
The second was when the
ballot boxes were taken
from Donald Trump,
who's a friend of mine.
Trump and I wrote two
books together, excuse me.
So, our freedom is
being taken away
and that's what
concerns me, David.
- Well, I think we just got
another great ally in the fight,
my friend, because
Ann is with us now.
- Yep.
- This is just the beginning.
I'll stay on top of
this story and you guys
are welcome back anytime.
- Thank you.
- Last word, it's
not about people,
it's about principles, let's
fight for our principles.
Thank you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.